uh what is mind Hunter did any of you
know what mindhunter is no no mind
Hunter's so good so mine hunter
unfortunately uh at least to my
knowledge is not going to continue I
think you can Google this
um it had two seasons and then for some
reason Netflix or I think some creative
staff involved didn't agree on some
stuff maybe Kai can fact check for me uh
but it's basically about uh it's a
really good Netflix like drama but kind
of loosely based on real events of why
the uh the FBI decided to start figuring
out what psychopaths are
um is this a drama or like a drama but
kind of loosely based on real events
very Loosely because you know they they
were a lot of the time you know way back
in America people were killing people
with similarly no motive and nobody can
understand why certain groups of these
people were very very organized would
didn't seem to care about the killings
would kill like 10 people and then some
people in the FBI are like huh I think
we should study these people who have
clearly very intelligent very good at
their crimes and who clearly are not
like the other criminals yeah right uh
so they're not like yeah right well you
know it's basically like this is where
it's a story about how basically
psychopath profiling started every true
Chrome fan
it's so good like the the acting the
shots the cinematography the pacing is
amazing do we have info
it's on indefinitely which basically
means it's done yeah and it's it sucks
so it is they go um in the first season
they basically you spend a lot of the
seasons with this this FBI guy who's
really dedicated to figuring out this
because he really believes that if if
they can figure out what makes these
Psychopaths tick and why they're doing
this that it can help them profile in
future and figure out how to stop this
happening yeah again this is all based
on like Loosely based on true events and
whatnot so the interview a very famous
serial killer uh over across the first
season called Ed camper who is like uh
oh yes I know very very famous yeah and
the actor in the series who portrays him
is insane he's so good I think I've seen
the clips of that the guy who like
killed his mother and killed his family
and then went on to kill and he killed
so many people and the only reason they
caught him is because he got bored and
turned himself in yeah right and he was
really well spoken didn't like you know
I've seen like interviews of the real
age really creepy guy really creepy
because he would just be like he he
would be willing to admit anything and
talk about it in full and so a lot of
the first season is just them talking to
him going back and forth trying to
convince the higher-ups this is worth
doing going back to Ed talking to him
the main character getting a little bit
too invested in talking to this serial
killer right and it's just really good
and it's it's just such a good human
drama whilst also kind of showcasing
like a really fascinating part of FBI
kind of history and this kind of how
they came up to start even doing this
yeah right every True Crime fan yeah and
then the second season I think they have
some Charles Manson stuff another famous
serial killer again it's all really
really interesting if you want a really
good kind of crime uh detective not to
say about like you know a really
unnerving drama okay is this did this
Series starts off with some guy blowing
off his head with a shotgun or something
you know I watched this when it came out
yeah and I remember that it's just been
one of those shows where I always check
every like month I'm like yeah is
anything happening because I really it
was getting so good yeah it's the dad
that went to go again yeah but even
because because the two seasons are so
good I still feel comfortable
recommending it being like this is such
still worth watching yeah it's so good
because because I remember Sydney was
like oh I want to watch a show it's it's
on Netflix and stuff like that and I'm
like what is it about and she was like
serial killers I'm like great okay okay
all right you're from Wisconsin I get it
okay I remember just like walking in the
room seeing someone blow the head off of
the shotgun
I can't I've got a massive spoiler no
problem it's like opening scene
um and I just walked out I was like
with a guy with the thing around his
neck and blew up or a shotgun definitely
shotgun okay that's the other evil but
if it was like a drama it wasn't like a
documentary I've seen it I've seen Evil
Geniuses that's that's good super
Geniuses game horrifying yeah yeah I
mean mindhunter is amazing if you want
just a great drama you want to be
fascinated enthralled you've got to
watch it it's on Netflix it's a shame
that we're not gonna get a season three
please bring back season three yeah so
Hannah Montana all right let's talk
about it yeah I mean again look you've
talked about you had a child a crush on
Hannah Montana but like sell me on the
show because I've seen oh no it's not
good but that's the thing I've seen bits
and pieces of the show it's not good at
all I think I think though is this your
guilty pleasure no
um I feel like this has a lot more uh
impact on me than I'd care to admit it
does I hate to be like but you know when
you're a child you're impressionable you
know at the end of the day I'm not
afraid to admit that Hannah Montana
changed my life then were you how did uh
the the change that mileage affect you
what's Hannah Montana about
I've not seen a single episode right so
there's it's a great question go on
fantastic question so there's Hannah
Hannah Montana yeah the stage name is
Hannah Montana it's this girl uh I can't
remember why she wants to be on stage
I'm sure just because her dad because
her dad is uh Billy Ray Cyrus who's in
like actual musician right um I'm sure
that I'm sure that helped get the show
Achy Breaky Heart yeah yeah so it's
about her who she's trying to get in
school but she doesn't want people in
school to know that she's a pop star so
she lives this dual life where it's it's
just Hannah she's living
yeah so that's the way the Best of Both
Worlds come from so she's trying to
balance the nobody nobody can know I'm
Hannah Montana yeah but also I got to go
to school but also gotta do these hit
performances yeah I don't know what her
real name is and her name in the show is
uh Hannah Smith
but I don't know it's just fun and I
think um in a weird way
um I think like the whole Hannah Montana
and the Disney and all that kind of got
me into like American culture a lot more
right right got me into the path of kind
of liking the idea of maybe performing
yeah because before that I had I had no
no desire in my bone to to perform or
get on a stage so basically you watched
Hannah Montana and you went I want the
best I I did want The Best of Both
Worlds and now as a social media person
I was like how about just one world and
I'll make that the best one you combined
the world think further Hannah go
further Beyond you're sorry I I don't
know in a weird way the Disney channel
has this weird kind of intoxicating
effect on kids that is like yeah you
want to be a little [ __ ] entertaining
little [ __ ] yeah
in a weird way I think it kind of does
it does it's just basically the you know
the the show for theater kids
everyone on the Disney show is like a
theater game I hate to admit it because
I think the show sucks in a weird way uh
but it was fun at the time and I was I
was obsessed with it again it just got
me into it and at a time where nobody uh
you know because I find in school
if you're not a theater kid yeah you are
never allowed to be a theater kid yeah
you can never join you know what I mean
there is a cut-off period if you are not
in the theater kid period by like age
eight you are not allowed in the theater
the thing the thing is you have to be
born and raised they're a ruthless Bunch
yeah where they lied to a bed at night
you can join the football team if you
get better you cannot become a theater
kid no no and that and that [ __ ] stays
with you oh yeah yeah like once a
theater kid always a thing you ever meet
someone and then they were like yeah I
was a theater kid and like I [ __ ]
knew it of course I knew it I can sense
it from the aura you know you feel the
pressure for sure
it stays with you dude I swear they
never drop it but again like in school I
I a part of me I had that tiny little
inkling I was like I'd love to try this
yeah but even at 10 I'm like the
window's gone because like you're like
yeah because the teachers wouldn't
wouldn't pick you yeah because they
would never give you the opportunity to
do anything because they were like well
we already know we like these kids yeah
we know who can these are the kids that
act yeah you're not the kid that acts
you're the kids at times the audition
and then we make the kids act feel good
because we can pick them you know it's
like and and this is a thing that I felt
in a weird way I hate Disney with a
burning passion I think they're a
terrible company uh but
predict where credit's due a little bit
of it kind of brought out that that I
was like [ __ ] you know I kind of wanna
but I didn't know how how do you how do
you get into it and that's kind of like
what kind of maybe planted the seed to
then when I found anime that made me
think actually I want a voice act did
you did you ever watch like High School
Musical yeah I didn't really want to
sing right something about acting kind
of spoke to me uh but it doesn't handle
the Tennessee yeah she sings but it was
kind of the acting part of it a lot of
these kid actors I thought they were
amazing yeah yeah props to the kid
actors I don't know how the [ __ ] they
did that yeah I can't act now bro um you
know and I think that planted the seeds
made me want to pursue something and
then discovered voice acting and that
was like stars aligned right so that
planted the seeds to me but also you
know I a lot of people like they can't
get into theater and I I like that
there's ways or kind of motivations
pushing us to do it because you know
like people like [ __ ] Gerard Butler
right or uh who we'll talk about later
uh uh [ __ ] uh uh Dawn and
um mad man what's his [ __ ] name in
real life Jon Hamm Jon Hamm you know
those two are both School teachers yeah
I just got into acting at like age 40.
and I love that [ __ ] I want more of that
yeah yeah I hate it when it's like if
you didn't act from age 10 get the [ __ ]
out of the industry you're a joke it's
like I hate that [ __ ] I think acting
should be like if you want to try it Go
the [ __ ] ahead if you don't if nothing
comes of it who cares yeah I think
having a way to express yourself and
having a way to perform is so uh just
fulfilling and satisfying I don't know
why [ __ ] Hannah Montana put that in
my brain but thank you Hannah Montana
thank you Miley expression Express
Yourself guys